let me let me pull up this uh story here
from uh uh well I I have a tweet here
for myself but it's a 5 38 story 538
says Democrats will hold the senate or
at least they're more likely to this is
why I always said when polling looks
good it may mean a red wave but three
months is still an electoral eternity
still 5 30 could be dead wrong what they
did was 40 000 simulations and they took
a random sampling or it just has a
sample of 100 outcomes showing that
Democrats win 52 in 100. I think as per
usual Nate silver and his cohorts are so
insanely wrong they've been wrong over
and over again they're probably wrong
now
how could Democrats possibly win in a
moment like this now I do think it is
within the realm of possibility they win
I just think the fact that it's leaning
in favor of Democrats makes no sense
when we've seen in Florida for instance
more Republicans registered to vote than
Democrats I think Florida is not a
Battleground State anymore right when in
Texas the Rio Grande Valley Republican
when you see safe blue districts in 2020
flip I don't know how they think this
could possibly happen other than the
fair the one point is there are more
Republican seats up for reelection than
Democrat seats I I remind people of last
year in Virginia a state that Biden won
by 10 points Glenn young essentially
wins by two 12-point swing in a year
that will be a year we'll have the
midterms a year after that the
trajectory has not changed for Joe Biden
it's gotten worse for Democrats as well
I I tend to think anything that's 12 13
14 15 points is actually in play for
Republicans yeah I think it's even to
the point where anything that Joe Biden
won by 20 points or less in 2020 is
actually competitive have you looked at
gallup's data on this when they talk
about first term uh Congressional losses
typically the Democrats have an
advantage and still lose rather rather
well the other thing is you've got I
mean it's hard to be it has happened
very rarely that historical Trends are
beaten
on average in the first midterm that a
party holds the white house since World
War II they've lost 28 House Seats and
four Senate seats they will have to have
to absolutely defy historical Trends 80
plus year about 80-year historical
Trends and defy the economy right gas
prices inflation the other thing I'll
remind people too don't under
Obama's Reuters approval rating was 44.7
October of 2010. we all know what
happened in November of 2010 63 House
Seats I think it was seven Senate seats
680 State Legislative seats I think Joe
Biden's average on Real Clear Politics
was 37 something or 38. uh Joe Biden's
aggregate approval rating recently
dropped lower than Trump's worst
possible uh aggregate rating so so Biden
is actually has a lower approval rating
at its worst Point than Trump ever did
so go I mean Obama's party got clobbered
in the 2010 midterms and he's running
about six seven points ahead of where
Biden is right now I mean there's just a
lot of different dynamics that are all
fully following into place I have a hard
time believing that Republicans aren't
going to pick up 35 40 C's in the house
I tend to think on the probably 53-47
Republican majority in the Senate I
think you guys are underestimating how
much people really want Ukraine to have
40 billion dollars for Vogue photo
shoots only up to 50 degrees or
something I can't remember that's a good
point I think they really liked those
Vogue photo shoots right guys they were
like you know what that was my tax
dollars hard at work I I just think at a
certain point the corporate propaganda
machine cannot overcome guests like
MSNBC can scream all day and night and
there may be some guy sitting in his
lawn chair being like wow Trump's so
awful then he gets up to go to the you
know go to work and go to the gas
station stops and looks at that number
and just starts crying oh the Monmouth
poll recently had the four top issues
that were most important to voters it's
all economic
elevation groceries do you know what do
you know where abortion falls on
gallup's uh polling of one percent yeah
one percent of people thinking it's the
most important issue have you seen what
rasmussen's been doing which I think is
really interesting the top eight issues
for voters the top eight issues I won't
call Mainstream media corporate
propagandists there's no correlation at
all between the top eight issues at all
not even close I mean for the corporate
propagandists climate change it's
January 6th that's all this other stuff
for the actual voters it's economy
inflation gas all of these things real
people issues yeah real people issues
and I think it's that I tell people the
closer you get to an election the
trajectories Harden and we're pretty
much into August we're just what 13
weeks out from the the midterms these
trajectories unless something absolutely
apocalyptic happens these trends of
Biden's going to have worse approval
inflation's not changing all of these
things and you're going to come in
November 8th and go
I am absolutely getting clobbered in the
economy and these guys want to tell me
that somehow climate change January 6th
I should have abortion on demand all the
way up to the point of birth wait a
minute you're not addressing my
day-to-day issues here get out yeah
there are some things that the political
gaslighting can't seem to overcome and
that money stuff is one of them I
remember in Canada when Trudeau started
bringing in the oh we're going to freeze
people's bank accounts for supporting
the truckers they immediately reversed
all rhetoric on that as soon as
Canadians started going straight to
their bank and withdrawing tons of money
out into Cash because they're freaking
out the bank started shutting down ATM
machines they started preventing
withdrawals and they were like holy all
right all right back pedal back pedal
back pedal this isn't good so I think
yeah when voters start seeing Oh my gosh
I'm not going to be able to pay for my
life then it's going to hurt the
politicians and then hopefully there'll
be some damn change because we need it
yeah I was thinking we could default on
the interest of the Federal Reserve
um and then say we'll pay you back
Federal Reserve we're going to return
our Federal Reserve notes and then give
people you know a U.S Bank
cryptocurrency in exchange and ever want
to lose 20 of the money they turn in uh
as some sort of currency as a massive
reset you have either that or just keep
your US Dollars and they'll be worth
nothing so it's up to you you can turn
them in and get 80 because the people
because that'll give a diminishing
return to the very wealthy so the poorer
you are the less you lose so it'll kind
of somewhat balance out the original
percentage losses the percentage lost
but if you have a million 20 is 200 000
if you have a thousand twenty percent is
and that and that's relatively
meaningful to a rich person and it's the
end of the world for a poor person if
you've got 100 you could do a J curve as
well you could have a scaling uh that's
why we do a progressive tax if you've
got hundred bucks and someone says we're
taking 20 of those dollars away from you
you're like that's my dinner on Friday
if you've got a million bucks and take
200 Grand you're like so I got 800 000 I
don't know yeah I'm up into a scaling
return uh uh I don't know diminishment
but we need some sort I I don't know a
massive reset to actually get out yeah
fed Reserve whatever they're doing what
was it three
point seven five or eight hike today
three the fourth time in this country
75.75 yeah 0.75 there's no there's
that's not even close to addressing
what's happening I saw someone tweet out
that's probably gonna have to be like a
20-point hike or something no no to
actually stop it I mean that's what they
did in the 80s didn't they yeah I think
it was it was it eight twenty yeah
something like that with Carter yeah I
mean you have to go massive drastic
action I guess what you're talking about
is a massive reset to say hey we have to
do something very dramatic at this point
to stop well I tell you man people need
to learn how to attend to their own
chickens get space to do so grow some
vegetables because learn how to process
deer like yeah yeah because the time may
come you know look we've been living in
a golden age we have we've I the the the
my lifetime I was thinking about this
where it's like I need to find a job
I'll go find a job you find a job and
you get paid 10 bucks an hour or
something you're living in in the city
maybe it's 12 bucks and then you're
paying your rent and there's no conflict
there's no there's there's no fighting
other than you know crime here and there
that stuff exists and then I'm just like
man every other other generation
throughout history people would just
randomly die like life was dangerous
you'd go out and you'd be like gotta go
get the water and then you'd fall in the
river you'd stub your toe and then be
like Oh I'm it's infected now I'm gonna
die that's how but now we have all these
modern luxuries we've secured our we had
secured borders to a certain degree and
so we our generation grew up with with
little to no conflict now this is what
you get from it we uh you know good
times make weak men weak men make bad
times
and so giving control of the economy to
Rockefeller and JP Morgan in 1913
basically people just got became their
their weakness just their deferment of
their responsibility of monetary control
was the weakness that's brought us to
this stage
I don't know man it's a lot of things
it's a lot of things I think um we've
got cultural decay is a huge component
of it I think but but I was thinking
about this recently we're a
self-governing republic but our Founders
didn't mean that we govern ourselves
it's we govern ourselves and I think
we've lost that concept of how does the
individual govern himself or herself we
could completely lost that concept it
starts with family I think this is
something I've had to like really you
know swallow the red pill on lately is
like I was raised in a really good
family with really good community and
when people spoke to me they told me the
truth my parents told me the truth they
weren't lying they weren't doing
underhanded things and that's how I
learned to interact with other people
and then I go out into the wider world
and I have no concept of people are
going to lie to me people are going to
do messed up things people are going to
try to set me up for failure and so I'm
interacting in the world in this way
that I learned at home and it's
absolutely screwing me over and the only
way to survive in the wider larger world
is for me to become like everyone else
and learn how to lie learn how to be
underhanded or learn how to spot it and
you don't really have a choice so when
people come up in broken homes and they
see their parents lying to them they see
them lying to each other they see them
just doing awful Behavior they learn
that's the way to survive in the world
and that's what our world has become
it's the product of a lot of broken
homes and people learning that lying is
the only way to get by but broken homes
you know I think to your point is not
just about poor homes it's about parents
who are just dejected and removed from
their kids or letting their kids do
whatever they want without there's no
discipline right no no strategy no no
expectations
um participation trophies where is the
parent to be like you lost son because
you weren't good enough train harder and
you can be better instead it's like I
want my kid to have a trophy too it's
not fair and then the kid cries gets a
free Trophy and thinks I didn't have to
do anything to get this yeah winning is
not the Trophy winning is the work
winning is doing the work to win being
able to win is is the real the process I
mean the way I see it is you know people
often say when they come hang out here
they're like wow you know look at this
thing that you've built and I'm like I
don't know man I wake up every day and I
just add one more thing to what I'm
doing sure if you came in look looked at
this facility now you'd be like how did
all this happen and I'm like this room
didn't used to be here that room didn't
used to be there that guitar didn't used
to be there it's like we walk up one day
and we're like oh yeah we'll put uh Ian
puts a rock on the table now Ian's got
like 50 rocks on the table they're
everywhere and it's just like one step
at a time you slowly get to that point
and you you have to treat life in my
opinion that's how you treat it the
there's the ends don't justify the means
because you never meet the end if every
day you live your best day you like I'll
tell you this people are like I want to
lose weight I did not lose weight
recently trying to lose weight I just
decided to eat better today so one day I
was like I didn't need any sugar or
grains
I'm just not going to then the next day
I was like well I shouldn't start now I
had a great day yesterday I should just
eat healthy today and then sure enough I
lose a bunch of weight my problem with
politics is like the people treat the
victory as getting the most votes so
that they get the office and they get
the scepter but like that makes people
do underhanded things to get the scepter
and that's not real victory for us we
need people to be their best and then
whichever one of them is chosen even the
one that isn't chosen still wins because
they did their best but like you're
saying that doesn't seem to be how
reality works because the strong take or
or whatever is going on there's not
enough to go around yeah I kind of view
it as like life hacking if you're
playing by all the rules you're just
gonna kind of stay in this you know
minimum wage kind of average salary
probably under 100K and then there's
people that will like morality hack and
they'll get to a next level you can lie
to people you can cheat people you can
get to all these higher positions when
you can like hack the system of morality
and
um that's that's how you get these like
Elites like Epstein that are like oh
we're just gonna literally sell children
we're going to sell other humans dude
we're going to make a ton of money we're
going to have tons of black people on
these yeah politicians we're going to be
able to control the world because we've
morality hacked we're not bound by any
freaking rules we can do whatever we
want to anyone on this planet thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there